I've got a funny break for you from the
despair of what's taken place over the
weekend with Saudi Arabia Trump 60
minute interview the proud boys beating
people up in New York City and this is a
break where we can just remind each
other that MIT Romney is still a
clueless clown and I want to see if you
can understand or explain the logic of
this to me
MIT Romney of course former
Massachusetts Republican governor former
Republican presidential nominee current
Utah Senate candidate he says that we
shouldn't impeach Donald Trump because
Trump is a sitting president that that's
the argument like I'm you're probably
waiting for me to say more about it
that's the whole argument impeachment is
on the table because he's the president
you don't impeach someone who's not the
president since they're no longer
president here's Mitt Romney giving us
this wisdom just a few days ago
I don't think it makes sense to be
talking about impeachment not for a
sitting president what I do believe and
I'll describe how I feel about the
president which is that over the last
couple of years what I've seen is a
number of things that frankly had
identify to one and some things I
wouldn't have done tell us which
presidents would you consider impeaching
if not the ones that are currently the
president like this is why we need
impeachment otherwise you just indict
him by definition impeachment is you
can't indict a sitting president
supposedly according to a number of
legal experts you have to impeach them
in order to be able to hold them
accountable if they have committed a
crime or acted inappropriately or
done done something that that it would
be worthy of impeachment or indictment
you can't indictment indict them so your
recourse is impeachment like what does
he mean you can't indict a city you
shouldn't be impeaching a sitting
president right in Romney's world you
shouldn't impeach them either so
apparently they are just above the above
the law should indict them either you
mean well usually you can't indict them
so many in the legal community say right
so you all sorted Romney you shouldn't
impeach them so even if the president
like murder someone there's no recourse
they just get away with it it's a
sitting president Pat what would you can
and you can't impeach a sitting
president their president after all this
is not even about the merits of a Trump
impeach
right like we haven't said anything
about the merits of impeaching Trump
it's about the stupidity of what Mitt
Romney is saying here if not for sitting
presidents for whom do you reserve
impeachment it's almost like Romney
doesn't know what impeachment is in some
way and I'm sure he must have been
thinking the exact same thing during
Bill Clinton's impeachment proceedings
right listen guys sitting president yes
you impeach him you're gonna interfere
with his ability to be President listen
I'm a free man right now
I shouldn't be tried of any crimes
because I'm free I'm a free man at this
at this time I want to remind you that
Mitt Romney was once a strong figure in
the anti-trump Republican movement he's
basically come fully over to Trump side
it seems his position now is it's worth
it for the tax cuts he called Trump a
phony at some point during the campaign
Boni and a fry Boni and a fraud he was
recently asked do you still think the
guy's a phony and now he said well you
know what I mean Trump's tax plan is a
good thing so it's basically like I want
the tax cut so I'm behind Trump at this
point surprise he's still sticking with
him after that frog legs incident yes he
was supposedly interviewed for Secretary
of State but then just completely
embarrassed yeah he's flip-flopped on
Trump like three or four times now but I
guess now he's holding firm well and
sadly his polling is holding firm as
well he's probably gonna be a senator
from from Utah he's polling like 55 to
60 percent against Jenny Wilson in Utah
still worth getting engaged in that 155
percent is not insurmountable and what
what unfortunately feels insurmountable
is the growing dystopia we find
ourselves in but that's why you need to
vote in November because for a movement
that claims to be against post-modernism
and relativism it is really strange how
the right now behaves as if words have
no meaning there's no fixed definitions
and anything can be anything when it
behooves them we are almost completely
out of time no voicemail today but we do
have a great bonus show we will talk
about the Kanye West Fiasco in the Oval
Office we will talk about a same-sex
penguin couple fostering an egg can you
imagine can you imagine that and we'll
also talk about increasing concerns
about DNA identifications as a result of
genealogy database
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show become a member
become a patron it's all happening today
I am thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink is calm
/ Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link in the description I
have listened to blinka spokes about
economics about political science about
history about science so many
interesting things and after the free
trial if you like it you can continue
enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about 5 bucks a month go
to blink is calm / Pakman that's B Li NK
is t.com /pa ke ma n